il est 20 heures le 14 mars 2020 lorsque
edouard philippe prend la parole on ne
sait pas encore mais nos vies vont
basculer dans le monde du confinement où
les masques et restrictions sanitaires
vont désormais rythmée nos vies en lien
avec le président de la république
j'ai donc décidé jusqu'à nouvel ordre la
fermeture à compter de ce soir minuit de
tous les lieux recevant du public non
indispensables à la vie du pays
il s'agit notamment des restaurants
cafés cinémas discothèques
parmi ces lieux non essentiels les
cinémas fermés depuis un an un an que
6114 salle et 2045 cinéma ont baissé le
rideau avec au total 240 4 jours de
fermeture et 15 mille salariés qui ne
peuvent plus travailler sans compter le
monde de l'audiovisuel et du 7e art avec
340 mille emplois touchés et les 400
films qui attendent toujours la
réouverture des salles pour sortir un an
vous ne vous êtes pas installé
confortablement dans ses sièges rouges
avec vos proches
la main dans le pop corn à regarder un
film tous ensemble et pourtant selon un
sondage et lab sept français sur dix
sont pour la réouverture des salles de
théâtre et des cinémas de nombreuses
mobilisations ont été organisées ces
derniers mois par le monde de la culture
pour protester contre la fermeture de
ces lieux culturels des lieux qui sont
finalement essentiel à notre
épanouissement
une crise qui frappe de plein fouet
plusieurs métiers comédiens chanteurs
danseurs régisseur et les intermittents
du spectacle qui travaillent en
coulisses et des professionnels du
cinéma en profiter de leur notoriété
pour ce faire les porte-voix de ce
secteur durement touché
guillaume canet léa seydoux jacques
audiard ou encore pierre niney se sont
adressés à emmanuel macron dans une
tribune publiée dans le monde
aujourd'hui nous pourrons donc encore et
toujours faire la queue pour aller
acheter des baskets ou une glace nous
entasser dans les supermarchés ou
prendre le train même bondé mais nous ne
pourrons pas aller au cinéma ni au
théâtre et cela malgré la mise en place
d'un protocole sanitaire des plus
strictes et des plus fiables dès le
premier jour du déconfinement au gré des
chiffres des variants des politiques
d'image d'annonce de culpabilisation ou
d'intimidation
nous avons le sentiment d'être éradiquée
votre silence est celui de votre
gouvernement sont en train de tuer le
cinéma français et plus généralement une
grande partie de notre culture
pour le moment aucune date précise n'a
été communiquée pour la réouverture des
lieux culturels
en attendant lé grand gagnant de cette
crise sont les sites de streaming en six
mois
netflix a comptabilisé 30 % d'abonnés en
plus depuis
comedia intermittents du spectacle les
militants ont occupé plusieurs théâtres
dans tout le pays pour protester contre
la fermeture des lieux culturels
une occupation jugé inutile et
dangereuse pour la ministre de la
culture
roselyne bachelot